oh man i ran out of gas dude this so
this would happen
[Laughter]
and shout out to the colin bro who works
here and who also apparently is the
freaking petrol plug man
because you caught him when you run out
of gas well he and i were supposed to
meet up here last
night oh sunday night last night i was
coming here last night
and i my car didn't have any more gas in
it and i said damn
i'm out of gas and he had to pick you up
and some people think here's what the
one thing i will give credit to myself
some people are like oh i don't know
i think the trans men i might have a
flat tire you always see some dumb girl
out there looking at all her tires
yeah like oh one of my tires is out of
gas i think
i heard a girl say that one time no
offense girls but also
a fence yeah dude last time i ran out of
dude
and i was telling a story brendan oh
sorry
and i was out of gas dude i knew
immediately so there's no bs in for me i
don't have to look under the hood and be
like oh damn
you know i need to call my stepdad yeah
no i know what's up i was out of gas
but uh here's what happened i was
supposed to watch the fights over uh
i was going over to david spades i met
up with him and dana carvey actually
which was pretty crazy to have some
dinner
so i get there and then the valet comes
back and says hey sir your car won't
start
so my car won't start over there and
it's uh and i said oh it's out of gas
and they got us looked at me and i was
like
did david spade see all this oh yeah i
was like do you you guys have any gas i
figured there's a lot of guys there
somebody's got a little bit of gas on
them
so he's like we don't have any gas here
and so i go out there
and this is noble or some [ __ ] that's
noble yeah right
standard yeah and so the standard so i
have to go so spade actually gives me a
ride to a couple gas stations to pick up
a gallon and get gas because you can't
put gas
this is a first and look i'm first
ballot run out of gasser
because i know that you can't get a milk
jug and fill it with gas
it has to be a the standard red yeah
because it will
be splashes around wouldn't it oh yeah i
got two right now in my thing yeah
but it will eat the it will eat right
through a milk jug so if you try to put
gas in the milk jug eat right through it
so don't try that's a cheap way out
because it's 22 for that red can
it's a dollar fifty for that gallon of
water empty it out and then spill gas
all over
yep so anyway i got the gallon of gas i
go back to my car
i didn't realize in the little spigot of
the jug they put a stopper in there you
got to take it out
so i put the thing into my gas tank all
the gas kind of goes into the thing but
then runs along
it comes out hot mess then the valet man
comes over and he says uh
brother brother in my country i'm a
famous mechanic in my country
um lie seem like a lot famous
unless you work at nordson's wrath
man i respect anybody that's
hard-working this guy's a hard-working
guy
yeah liar but yes and he's like you have
bigger problem bigger problem you know
you have splash bad splash you know and
i'm telling them look it's just the can
so anyway i had to go take an uber
and at this point gas is pooled all in
front of the gas the gallon i did have
pooled out in front there's people
waiting to go sit down it's like a nice
restaurant
everybody's pissed one old guy keeps
trying to smoke and they keep stopping
him and i think he doesn't understand
why so he's all pissed you know so
anyway fast forward finally bro it was
about an hour and a half ordeal i went
and got two more gallons of gas got back
there
i had gas all up and down my arms the
entire scent though
i don't mind this smell i don't mind it
i just get nervous because i forgot to
shower and then i went to sleep
and i got nervous i woke up and had a
scary dream but it's fair um
anyway man yeah i ran out of gas one
time around i guess one time well
more than one but the one i remember i
just not
i just knocked out biggest one of my
card knocked out murco crow cop i'm in
denver right so i'm like cloud nine
and i bought a [ __ ] hummer h2 a big
ass hunter like arnold schwarzenegger
and i'm the most brandon thing you could
do yeah in denver they're dope
drive thing gas i'm like i can push it
runs out of gas so i have to put in it's
in the middle of the [ __ ]
intersection right around oh so i'm put
trying to push this [ __ ] hummer to
the gas i get the gas station
yo man do you have one of those things
and he's like what happened with granite
gas and he's like yeah we got one that
goes
it was literally the weekend before i
beat croquet was
aren't you the ufc fighter or yeagers
did you just beat [ __ ] merkel
crocodile i go yeah around the gas he
goes
damn that's sad
he's just sad on me he's sad man he's
right we used to do gas
and goes all the time but then the
conicals got smart because remember you
they didn't have the card you have to go
inside so you could pump gas then pay
so my mom was like i'm low on gas can
you guys get me gasps i mean my brother
just
pull up i would pump fill it up or drive
off
that was a thing oh stealing gas pump
and jump they call it wow
yeah i remember a cop came one time i
was at my friend's house taking a nap
and um
cop came and knocked on the door and
accused me of stealing gas
and i had been pumped pump and go
[Music]
is